yeah because they never yeah
Modern Men because they like the baddest
[ __ ] I mean I don't see it's
interesting
you know what's interesting especially
with you and like other girls that come
on the show whenever we talk about women
like they always have to say but men
because it's interesting
we don't we don't go into the women's
conversation and say and to the women's
conversation and say but Matt but why
don't we just say but people but people
why is it so Divine because this is my
podcast
but like it's like kind of like
entitlement you want to come on here and
tell me how to write my podcast and how
to run the conversation
I know but sometimes you can make a
statement about women without saying but
men the same way we could State make a
statement about men without saying but
women
the genders are different there's
different things but when that when
something applies to both genders like
men being cheated on women and now we
know that men and women so why wouldn't
we say people these days prefer because
they choose women cheat more so what
does that tell you about Modern Men
they're choosing cheating women so why
are we
yeah so my point actually is so you're
kind of derailing the combo so not not
even talking about this the reason I
think water women like to be cheated on
is because they catch him cheating they
never leave and I've had girl after girl
after girl after girl and sometimes they
do but whenever I ask when did you leave
it's never when they catch him cheating
it's like when he stops it's like it's
too late now it's like no no it's like
they cheat they catch them and then six
months later then you leave
yeah you could have you could have left
when he was cheating so so in my head
it's like when he's cheating when she
has actual evidence of him cheating she
stays when she has no evidence of him
cheating she leaves so modern women like
to be cheated on that's my point Modern
Men I've never heard men say oh I was
cheated on and I stay because they don't
admit it I'm a therapist I work with men
who just stay with cheating women you
don't work and be around that but if you
if you are around it you see men all the
time saying I got with this guy I know
she was a bit loose she had her pictures
out on Instagram I know she slept with
one of the guys I knew but I still loved
her I got married at you're selecting
cheers as well
why did they stay
the whole point the whole point is like
when he's cheating she's staying when he
stops she leaves the men don't men don't
typically leave relationships women
leave 90 of the time if they're college
educated they're not likely to leave
even if a woman's cheating in marriages
they're more likely to stay because
let me take half of your assets up to 70
in the UK and your kids I mean it's not
like they want it's not what I do the
governments the government's making them
stay they have to stay they have no
choice yeah but they they pick cheats
but you agree with that right yeah yeah
do you have a choice especially when
you've got kids because then you lose
kids with women when we leave we don't
lose our kids you lose your kids but I
do think that men pick cheaters as well
because you'll see the girls who've got
clear red flags that I'm gonna cheat her
bodies out on Instagram she's lots of
guys know her whatever it is they're the
girls that get the most attention and if
you didn't want a cheating woman you
wouldn't cheat
relationship yeah but where does you
said where does relationship starts
through sex you said that early in your
cupboard because they started
sex but who wish women would make it to
the final rounds not the Unfaithful ones
you'd be not not for the men with the
options I agree they're a desperate set
there's a synth epidemic yes there is a
Sims epidemic yeah but the men the men
that have the choice I don't think they
pick cheaters men that have the choice I
do but Alpha men like I was saying in
the alpha men don't pick cheaters not at
all but the majority of men aren't Alpha
and they choose who's beautiful you're
saying she is like it's a blood type
someone someone can be in a situation
and they just get lost in the sauce and
they [ __ ] up or they choose to go and
cheat it's not it's not like a oh this
person is a cheater that person there
are definite signs but someone has to
cheat First Once at least I mean so
before they cheated the whole the whole
point is that when he's cheating she
stays when he's not cheating she goes
like I don't I don't see the same thing
for men where when she's cheating he
stays when she's not cheating he goes
yeah yeah but I do but it doesn't add up
statistically if you're saying women
file for divorce more and women cheat
more that tells us that women are being
selected more and they're the ones
choosing to leave so men aren't leaving
cheaters and they're choosing them that
doesn't add up statistics say that again
so if women are more likely to divorce a
man and women are more likely to cheat
that shows us that men are more likely
to stay with cheaters women are the ones
exited there's a simple epidemic that's
absolutely statistics I think also maybe
the the women aren't cheating first
maybe because I think you know the woman
will stay with the man that's cheated
for a little while and then she'll find
you know the jujitsu guy or the best
friend or the Cassie and Diddy kind of
situation yeah that's true and then that
that betrayal is so much that he just
you know I mean yeah maybe they're not
cheating first they're not cheating for
this anymore
no I think that it's like the women I
mean I think it's mostly like the girls
settle with the like the beta guy or the
guy she didn't really I mean I want to
say subtle it's really her level but she
settles with the guy she doesn't want
and then cheats with the guy she does
[Music]
I can't speak on that do you think I I
don't I wouldn't be able to I've never
been with this teacher
I don't I don't know what I'd be honest
I don't cheat I don't know what that
Vibe what it is
um so I can't really speak on it but I
do think you know when a girl's able to
cheat just like when you know with a man
I disagree you know I swear to God
there's this girl oh my god I've told
the story on my on my podcast before I
don't think you know there's a girl on
my on my
maybe be careful sometimes I'll be
finding these people there's a girl on I
was on three different teams so there's
a girl on a team I was on in college
yeah and literally she was a girl next
door you would never know she seemed
like the sweetest chick and I swear to
God she had a a guy she dated her
freshman year of college did him for a
month he cheated he was like all around
town or whatever her senior year
um she was with a guy that bought her
bought her a house she moved in and I
was like yeah yeah I've told it before
and I was at a party and literally like
her and her body wasn't on Instagram she
was a school teacher good with kids
sweet nice like and literally she was in
the bathroom with the guy from freshman
year at the party her boyfriend came to
and and my chill he bought her house he
bought her at home
and that was kind of a red pill moment
for me where I was like God damn you
would never know yeah and I also maybe
because I live in Dubai and I see a lot
where these men are setting the women up
they're getting them nannies getting
them drivers and they're using that
spare time and his money to go on dates
with their boyfriend and that's where I
think they're cheating on the women's
side is so much worse because she's
doing it on his clock and on his money
I've seen it firsthand that it's like
with his car they're going out too
that's that's simple though yeah like
but they'll be okay with it because they
they want to cheat as well so there's
like as long as there's a lot of people
there's a lot of open marriages in
Hollywood and stuff so do you think it's
just a way forward sadly what both
people cheating
[Music]
I think it's just it's different it's
different it's not I think everyone says
we're cheating and and stuff like this
in general it's just like everything's
the same
the men can cheat so therefore women can
cheat and women and men cheat the same
way and we just cheat as much it's all
nonsense and it's completely different
sure both sexes cheat both genders cheat
whatever but the men are doing it for a
different reason to the women are and
the women are doing it from different
ways I mean I think as a woman if you're
if you have an Instagram that's open and
you got like like sexual pictures I
think that's cheating yeah
and they picked that girl
I think that's worse
I'm Caribbean I've never seen back one
CFC we have our Carnival yeah so our
costumes as you know they are very
revealing so me personally like I had
this conversation about guys many many
years ago that my ex I'll see it was my
guy about my ex she would dress up in
the most when it comes to carnivore and
all you really see is is a little little
brother that covers a nipple look who's
on the covers the Taunton and big old
feathers now me personally not her
Instagram
I don't mind any of that to me I don't
see that as being cheating because I'm
okay with it it's only cheating if you
as your spouse is not okay with it and
you're still doing it against it
you don't think that's an invitation was
she advertising she could advertise to
the ball babe the world touching it so
can't you make only friends
yeah we breaking all the plants together
your definition is because the
definition of cheating is there has to
be some level of sexual intimacy and
there has to be some level of secrecy if
there's no secrecy then it's not
cheating so I think he's right yeah so
if you're in an open relationship it's
not cheating
I think accepting I mean look if if
you're in if you're in a relationship
and you know you're with a guy that says
it's okay you know it's kind of the same
thing as like being with a woman or like
with a guy that's like a woman that says
it's okay to sleep with other girl like
but I just think attention is currency
to women and you're like accepting
attention from other men like I just
that's disrespectful that notion is
disrespectful no because it's how you
receive this how they receive it is only
a matter of time before somebody that is
giving the attention is someone that she
wants to reciprocate the attention to
it's only a matter of time is supposed
to come into it
you're supposed to put borders around
and boundaries around to limit the
environment so this culturally that's
normal for myself we act about if I can
go to a club and wine and shock upon 15
20 guys knowing that yeah but I'm not
taking No Instagram no numbers no no and
I'm going home to my account and I'm
still cutting up in bed
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible